in the lobby of Ramsey solutions they're
here a Cory and Alisha are with us hey
guys how are ya I was up with up is they
good to have you where do you guys live
Lafayette Louisiana
all right very fun been there spoke at
the First Baptist Church downtown we did
an event there one time yes they many
many or is it many years ago a great
town well welcome to Nashville and here
to do your debt-free scream yes I love
it how much have you paid off
Lee over ninety two thousand dollars
very cool and how long did that take
nine nine thirty thirty nine thirty
months and your range of income through
that thirty months we started off around
one hundred and forty five then we
jumped up to 175 Wow very go on the
verge to do about a hundred eighty-five
this year's good for you guys what do
you guys do for a living I'm a
registered nurse ah um promise you don't
laugh okay I'm a private investigator
okay and a pastor okay I don't know how
they go together I'm thinking that
there's probably opportunities on both
sides for these two work together yeah I
can see a pastor needing some private
investigation going on I'm thinking the
pastor private investigator might need
some pastor and going on it's definitely
very fun so obviously pretty lucrative
very well done good good and obviously a
nurse you can pick up a lot of hours and
you've been doing that I'm guessing well
not too much but a little bit okay she's
making she been making me work day yeah
you look like you're gonna make it you
go survive so what kind of debt was the
90 mm um 401k loan mm-hmm two cores um a
little medical debt mm-hmm
credit cards mm-hmm her student loan
mm-hmm that's pretty much it you had
everything had everything your normal
yes yes figured out normal sucks though
yeah hey so so what happened 30 months
ago that made this switch flip and you
guys go okay we're getting out what what
day we was we knew the budget we
we had a budget but we just started
saying making too much money
mm-hmm not to have any money mm-hmm and
and and we was getting to the point it
was starting to affect the marriage in a
very very bad way and and we began
praying and one day I was driving back
to Lafayette from Baton Rouge and I was
just flipping through the stations and I
heard this man by the name of Dave
Ramsey talking mm-hmm and and I listened
all the way back from Lafayette to Baton
Rouge was about an hour way so I
listened for that whole hour and I
looked into it and then when I finally
came home I told a leash I said oh I've
been listening to this fella by the name
of the Rams and something you need to
check out mmm okay all right
and so you jump online and found the
every dollar budget or got you out in a
class or what'd you do then um what we
tell them over there well the first
thing we we um we signed up for a class
okay one of the local churches good and
we did the 1990 class okay cool cool
that gives you that gives you the track
to run on right yeah you're ready to go
then I very cool so you were just ready
I mean when the you know the old saying
is when the student is ready the teacher
will appear right we was doing so bad if
I would have came home and say let's run
around the house seven times and then I
get out of debt you were to try it
because you're so desperate I really
showed em here yeah let the walls of
Jericho fall exactly exactly exactly
I'm ready good for you guys very well
done and you did this in 30 months I
mean when y'all got on you went on hard
then yes yes yes went all in a lot of
sacrifice out of sacrifice
what was the craziest wildest sacrifice
one for me it was not being able to shop
like I wanted to mm-hmm um and eating
out eating out eating out have to hit
hardest from from me ya know eating out
yes okay a lot of red beans and rice I
love it
that's very good Oh fun that made my
mouth water but I bet there's some good
red beans and rice right there Lafayette
oh yeah
oh man well congratulations you guys
so now pastor when somebody comes to you
and your congregation says hey I'm in
debt and they say how did you pay off
92,000 what are you telling the secret
to getting out of debt is first I bring
them to my office and and I basically
tell them two things that really work
for us um a budget you got it you got to
have a budget you you got to have a
budget and the second thing that did it
for us
um was the envelopes definitely
envelopes like I say we had the budget I
knew what the Word of God said about
money
I knew that you're supposed to be a good
steward up over your money and and we
was doing we looked at the budget but
something just wasn't clicking mm-hmm
until I heard about the envelopes and
and that's what did it for us
discipline okay right discipline I gave
you the guidelines yeah yeah gave you
the out-of-bounds marker and blow the
whistle when you're out of bounds dang
huh exactly yeah cool congratulations
you guys I'm very proud of you thank you
a lot of debt you get off how's it feel
now to Bellary oh I tell people it makes
you feel so light what you like mmm
it's no heavy nice on you no pain I
don't you funny thing is it creeps up so
gradually that you don't realize how
much weight there is to it right until
it's gone until it's gone until it's
going in when you get down to the last
line on your budget and you realize you
got all this money left mm-hmm like wow
wow wow well you guys make good money I
mean y'all Abell make some serious
progress now we should be [ __ ] out I
mean you're gonna live like no one else
now you'll be able to live and give like
no absolutely right
absolutely at aligning you know that
that scripture this is very true in
these situations no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest all right yeah mr. Rochester
absolutely absolutely that's right where
you're staying are you exactly your
heroes man I'm proud of y'all thank you
thank goodness the number ones
best-selling book by my friend Chris
Hogan that works here on our team
and that's the next chapter in your book
right become very wealthy and
outrageously generous and you've got the
tools to do that you got the math to do
that here and now you know we're out of
bounds is
and right on how to live how to live
inside the lines stay in the lines and
make this work and so we'll give you a
copy of that cool thank you for being
here and making the trip all the way
from Louisiana to do your debt-free
scream Chris was the first person that
we saw live when we first started in
2013 he came to them
I think the Bethany Church in Baton
Rouge yeah okay you sure did
Wow I remember that event very cool well
I'll have to pass it on to him yeah here
you are the partly because of his aunt's
right standing here right now very good
stuff alright it's Corey and Alicia
Lafayette Louisiana 92 thousand dollars
paid off in 30 months making 145 to 175
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're dead
oh I love it
well done you guys very very well done
this stuff this money stuff is not hard
to understand it's just hard to do and
you know what that couple did their
courageous they looked in the mirror and
said you know we're not going out to eat
you know we're not going to do this
we're not going to go shopping we're
going to get our life back we have
surrendered our life to the creditors
the borrower is slave to the lender
we're not going to live like this
anymore and when you make a decision and
you commit you can change your life
that's exactly what Corey and Alicia
just did very cool very cool couple
that's powerful you can do this and you
know what you might be that person was
praying and asking God you know I need
some help I need some help need some
help and randomly or at least you
thought it was randomly you just
accidentally at least you thought it was
accidentally landed on this radio
station just now and you're hearing this
right now and this is the first time
you've ever heard the show and you hear
that couple get on here and say they
paid off ninety two thousand dollars in
debt well let me help you with this it
wasn't random
and the wasn't accidental and it wasn't
luck you're supposed to do this yeah you
I'm talking to you
it's time for you to get out of that so
you get your life back you're giving
everything away to other people and you
work too hard for that stop it this is
the Dave Ramsey
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
Oh